Republicans are widely trying to
ridicule and discredit obviously
credible Trump impeachment inquiry
witnesses one of whom is Lieutenant
Colonel Alexander VIN Minh we did a
fantastic job yesterday
but this is more than political this is
very real this presents a real risk to
the witnesses and their families we
already talked about Trump considering
firing or trying to fire some
impeachment witnesses but there's a new
report from The Wall Street Journal
which reveals that the US Army has a
plan in place and is ready to at a
moment's notice
move Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN
Minh and his family to a secure location
for his safety if he is found to be in
danger they have been contingency
planning for exactly this reason we
learned that army security is tracking
VIN Minh and VIN man's family 24-hours a
day in case there are threats now it's
understandable that they don't want to
provide more details about the specific
security protocols and actions but it is
very clear that this is no joke now when
I told you some time ago we protect
whistleblowers in part because it puts
them in danger to be known I meant it
now VIN Minh isn't the whistleblower he
is a whistleblower whose identity is
publicly known and look at what is going
on consider how wretched what's going on
is VIN Minh is testifying because the
president is accused of bribery and
extortion of a foreign country for
political gain and the person who has to
be careful is the witness because of the
president's actions and the president's
a sailing of the witnesses character and
because of the president's followers
Trump should be scrutinized not VIN Minh
here who is fulfilling his oath showing
up telling what he knows now there are
trumpets coming up with stuff like well
trumps the president meaning he's the
commander-in-chief of the military so
VIN Minh is in the wrong for going
against Trump's wishes for reporting on
Trump members of the military should
ignore orders that they believe are
wrong or illegal
I was just obeying orders that doesn't
work and yeah you might have a
problem that needs to be adjudicated by
the code of us MJ but let's reverse this
the issue here is not vin Minh the
president who is the commander in chief
of the Armed Forces is calling VIN means
loyalty into question the
commander-in-chief is using his
surrogates like these Republicans on the
House Intelligence Committee to attack
VIN Minh to imply VIN Minh is maybe a
foreign agent or a spy or has dual
loyalty a known anti-semitic trope which
we will deal with a little bit later
they are truly the sick ones where are
the supporters of the military why
aren't we hearing from them against
Trump's attacks on ving Minh we are
talking about an active-duty lieutenant
colonel in the military who is taking
great personal risk because of them he's
at risk to come in and testify who
served in Iraq was blown up in 2004
thankfully as he said yesterday suffered
minor injuries relative to the two
others that were serving with him at the
time and the reason why they're not
supporting the military as they claim to
is because it's always been a show we
have quick quickly learned that under
this immoral president anything about
supporting the troops is bogus and we've
also learned bigger picture and this
really makes me sad that the military
has always been mere political props for
Republicans it's never really been about
support the troops because if they did
they wouldn't send them into harm's way
for political reasons they would ensure
that they actually have the health care
that they need they wouldn't say like
Trump did that if you have PTSD after
serving you're simply not strong enough
I mean these are really sick things to
say they've always been political props
I hope now it's becoming abundantly
clear that this has always been the case
let's take a quick break
follow me on instagram at david pakman
follow the show on instagram at david
pakman show